foreign
the world is drowning in debt okay maybe
not the whole world but enough of it
that we should worry people are
suffering really badly and yet we have
done nothing to prevent this
in this video we'll talk about whether
we should expect more scenes like this
as crises and conflicts make it ever
more expensive to borrow
things have changed very dramatically
um you know the the Ukraine war
accelerated uh a a tightening in Global
Financial conditions and we'll also
discuss what should be done to diffuse
the ticking Time Bomb of global debt
Predator economies actually benefit from
debt forgiveness wholesale right off I
think also sends the wrong message
that's all coming up on business Beyond
[Music]
here's a situation the international
monetary fund says 60 percent of
low-income countries are at high risk of
debt distress or in debt distress
already what does that mean at its
simplest it means these countries are
having trouble settling their
commitments and need debt restructuring
that's where the terms of the loans are
tweaked in order to enable easier
repayment some countries are already in
default like Lebanon Sri Lanka Russia
Suriname and Zambia seen here in red but
other countries are teetering
dangerously close albeit in varying
degrees that the world economy is facing
a set of challenging circumstances isn't
helping
accelerated inflation
it has become a clear and present danger
for many countries
Rising food and fuel prices are
straining the budgets of ordinary
families to a Breaking Point
Financial tightening
because of the need to counter inflation
hitting countries with high debt the
hardest
first the pandemic meant that while
richer countries could spend more to
keep their economies afloat others found
themselves hamstrung by their existing
debt obligations obligations that have
since become even harder to meet
the inflation-fighting measures by the
Federal Reserve have led to a stronger
dollar and increased difficulty in
paying down dollar denominated debt
the current economic climate means words
like a perfect storm are thrown around a
lot but debt crises are nothing new one
might ask oneself why borrow or for that
matter lend in such a way that spells
later difficulty in other words how did
we get here
start of the century you can pretty much
Post 9 11 we've had very very ultra low
rates across the board that's been
exacerbated by monetary easing low rates
aren't great for investors right so if
you're a US investor or european
investor looking to deploy Capital
um you're not going to be deploying it
domestically when when you're not really
getting a return on that on that Capital
so you're looking for higher yield
opportunities and Emerging Markets where
the kind of the the perfect destination
for that now that bit is important
emerging in Frontier Market debt is
associated with higher risk but also
potentially with higher returns for
investors back to the story
oh look you know you should access
Global Capital markets and that way you
will get finance that you need that will
augment your domestic savings and so
across the world countries were
encouraged to open up their capital
accounts allow much career borrowing by
their domestic companies emerging
markets and Frontier markets became
embroiled in This Global Financial
system and for a while it was all hunky
dory it was nice because we're getting
all this extra extra money or domestic
companies when there was a crisis when
crunch time came then suddenly all of
these creditors say well we want full
repayment in other words they got the
benefits of IRS premium but they're not
willing to take on any of the risks
as we've established that crunch time is
now and if before low interest rates in
the world's top economies pushed money
out of them towards Emerging Markets
there are different factors at play now
JP Morgan says investors have pulled 50
billion dollars from Emerging Market
bond funds in 2022.
things have changed very dramatically
um you know the the Ukraine war
accelerated uh a a tightening in Global
Financial conditions meaning that U.S
rates are rising uh uh and and that of
course starts to reverse some of that
Dynamic that I talked about with low
rates pushing money out higher rates are
going to bring money back in
the ebb and flow of money all around the
world may sound abstract but they have
very real consequences for people on the
ground
at this stage we're all familiar with
the food and fuel shortages that befell
Sri Lanka after it ran out of dollars to
pay for imports in Lebanon a sliding
currency amid a sharp economic downturn
led to bank hold UPS by desperate
depositors trying to get their Cash Out
devastating floods exacted a heavy human
and economic toll in Pakistan at a time
when the economy was already reeling
from a balance of payments crisis the
details May differ but the pain is
widespread it's compromises the rights
of the people down at the ground it's
the ability for them to access food and
for exchange to buy food when it's
necessary
um and we're seeing it with some of the
the wars and humanitarian crises that
are emerging in Eastern Europe for
example right now and it it's really it
is a it is definitely exacerbated by the
entire structure uh in the system there
is a needs to have a fresh death
architecture let's say Ghana joins the
default clip then the creditors are
saying well oh my goodness let's look at
Tunisia then let's look at the
neighboring countries then you get much
much more debt stress across the
developing world that would actually
destabilize the Global Financial system
and I do believe that that is very
likely because of the inaction that
we've been so far when countries need
bailouts from the IMF the IMF is going
to want to make sure that that loan
isn't being used to service existing
debt often that means getting other
creditors to agree to debt restructuring
but who are are those other creditors
it's complicated alongside multilateral
lenders like the World Bank and the
international monetary fund you also
have a group of major creditor countries
who coordinate on debt repayment issues
as members of the so-called Paris Club
but you also have creditor Nations who
aren't part of this club like China
these days however private creditors
like BlackRock also hold much way the
big problem today is really that it's a
much more complex scenario now for
deadly workouts you know when the hipic
initiative happens the highly indebted
poor countries initiative which was a
debt relief package way back in the
2000s that was just a public bilateral
and multilateral project okay and that
was kind of easy to do governments could
get together and decide now 60 70 of the
debt that most countries have is held by
private creditors and a lot of it is in
bond market
how do you actually manage a
restructuring how do you get the private
sector also to do it experts like jayati
gauche who we just heard there say that
more has to be done to compel private
creditors to coordinate more on lending
and restructuring others point out that
private entities get a lot of backing
from the government too especially in
times of financial distress very often
private sector entities are getting paid
out
but what we're seeing is a rhythm which
is after the bailout or the support of
subsidies a year later or two years
later the very often the same entities
actually declare windfall profits and
I have a different question to it is if
you were subsidized as a corporation
earlier then why don't you return the
subsidy why don't we see subsidies also
in a sense as a debt that that company
now owes to the states that has kept it
alive during a tough uh scenario
speaking of tough scenarios the pandemic
prompted the G20 to introduce the debt
service suspension initiative that saw
nearly 13 billion dollars in payments
suspended from May 2020 to December 2021
to dozens of countries before that
period ended the G20 and the Paris Club
also launched the common framework for
debt treatments to help countries with
debt restructuring and liquidity
insolvency issues it also required
private creditors to provide comparable
debt relief although it's far from Clear
how the common framework can make this
happen so far only three countries have
applied for debt restructuring under the
program as it happens a country
signaling that it needs some help comes
with a sort of stigma potentially
impeding its ability to borrow in the
future one country which did sign up for
the common framework is being watched
very closely in 2020 Zambia was the
first country to default on its debt in
the pandemic era at the end of 2021 its
external debt stood above 17 billion
dollars
the country was lagging behind in terms
of the quality of the infrastructure
especially to support economic growth so
that was understood I think the
challenge was how some of this
investment was then undertaken if I was
to put it simply a user illustration is
like economic indigestion we took on a
lot more than we could actually put to
good use in the time in which we took to
absorb it
Zambia a country largely dependent on
Imports sought citizens Battle Rising
prices as the Zambian kwacha depreciated
while foreign currency reserves went to
servicing debt
they receive mixed messages from the
government as to how that was being
handled we had a period where the the
country and the government was
acknowledging that the debt was starting
to become unsustainable
there were actions that were announced
to try and bring debt back into line
however at the same time there were
actions that were being undertaken which
seems to contradict on one hand we say
we're going to slow down on debt
contraction a few days later there will
be announcements around new projects
that need to take off all of that
obviously then sort of causing a bit of
Disconnect between the intention and
what is actually being done fast forward
to today under President hakain
Zambia has now managed to secure a 1.3
billion dollar assistance package from
the international monetary fund
following months of discussion and after
bilateral creditors including China
agreed to negotiate a debt restructuring
deal with Zambia many are looking at
Zambia as a test case for how China
treats debtor countries who are
struggling to pay and as an indicator of
China's preparedness to work with other
creditor countries as it does so
beijing's belt and Road program where
ambitious infrastructure projects in
nearly 150 countries were financed with
billions in Chinese loans has helped
transform China into the world's biggest
lender to developing nations but it has
had to field accusations of trapping
borrower governments in loans with a
goal of seizing critical assets once
they were unable to pay
others doubt the fairness of the
argument well I've always been very
skeptical about the debt trap diplomacy
claim I think it's easier to explain
what China did as an example of
inexperience and maybe even a certain
amount of foolishness rather than any
really nefarious plan and I think it
pays to be a little bit cynical here I
think International creditors are using
the excuse of China
not to Grant a a forgiveness or
forbearance and China is using the
excuse of international creditors to
make the same complaint so each side is
saying in principle we would be willing
to be
easier going but we don't want to relax
credits simply for you to use that and
repay the other
let's go back to Zambia China holds
about a third of its external debt after
years of resisting coordination on debt
restructuring beijing's treatment of
Zambia has attracted a lot of attention
could this be a turning point in getting
countries to cooperate I think there are
still too much political jaw boning and
criticisms going back and forth which
makes each side very suspicious of the
other but ultimately what we've always
seen if you study the history of of
sovereign debt particularly during
periods of great trouble what we've
always seen is that eventually we become
reasonable and recognize that the debt
can't be repaid and the only way to
revive growth is with significant debt
forgiveness there is never a Revival of
growth without significant debt
forgiveness significant debt forgiveness
has come up here before if the problem
is that there is too much debt that
cannot be repaid then the idea that
canceling some of that debt is necessary
should be fairly obvious there's
widespread consensus that that is in
fact what's needed but views diverge on
how much some write off is definitely
required wholesale write-off I think
also sends the wrong message in terms of
what it means to borrow and be
responsible in terms of being able to
repay because at the end of the day
um it's not as though uh the the debt is
forced on any particular country in most
circumstances some of that debt is
bilateral some of it multilateral some
of it to private creditors now I take a
very pragmatical uh view on this issue
in that in those private creditors for
example fund managers they are managing
resources that have been entrusted to
them by depositors at the extent in the
in the case of commercial banks in the
case of Pension funds pensioners and
they are savings so when we say that
they should be right off there is
obviously consequences on the other side
of the equation
but there is also the perspective that
greater restructuring stands to benefit
not just the borrowing Nations but the
lending ones
the world needs
probably to get much more serious about
restructuring this debt uh and I would
argue the the world should do it not
just because it's better for Pakistan
and Sri Lanka or Zambia or or or or
Venezuela but it's also better for us
and what I would argue is that the less
money is used to repay debt than by
definition the more money is used to
import from the rest of the world which
means importing from the U.S Europe Etc
so we actually benefit the the Creditor
economies actually benefit from debt
forgiveness even if the creditors don't
always benefit more generally however
this poly crisis movement might have led
to a shift in thinking when it comes to
lending about what it means to inject
external money into a country's finances
when the West lends to Emerging Markets
that's a good thing because it allows
Emerging Markets to grow it raises the
standard of living lifts countries out
of poverty and and globalization has
definitely been a Force for good in that
sense but there are downsides to that
when you have situations like we're in
today where capital is coming out of the
country you can scratch your head and
say well why on Earth did I why on Earth
did I borrow that much why did I why did
I allow that much hot money to come into
my economy I should have put some sort
of controls in place to prevent
foreigners from coming into my local
market which prevent foreigners from
buying up uh you know local local assets
or depositing local bank accounts and
perhaps a shift in perspective of this
kind could be key to avoiding the next
debt crisis after all the more lenders
acknowledge they're in a symbiotic
relationship the greater the incentive
not to see their debtors fail and that's
all for this edition of business Beyond
if you enjoyed this video why not check
out some of the others that we have I
personally would recommend our Deep dive
into the future of Europe don't forget
to hit like And subscribe thank you so
much for watching